hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and I am John humm we're gonna check out
today from what culture 10 awesome
opening scenes and otherwise terrible
films but before we do that we wanted to
give a shout out to today's video
sponsor Kendall Capcom so guys the
holidays are coming Black Friday is
almost here and before you know it it's
gonna be whichever winter holiday you
choose to celebrate and if you're in
need of a gift for that special somebody
or just some goodies for yourself then
definitely check out Kendall Capcom
they've got a wide variety of products
ranging from electronics to clothing
collectibles accessories and more and
they also offer free worldwide shipping
on orders over $50 and if you hit up our
special link Kendall cup comm slash real
rejects link in the description box and
enter our promo code real rejects you
can get an extra 15% off of your order
holy Black Friday Batman our discount
code is applicable to any and all
purchases you make in the Kindle Cup
store so hit that link check out the
site and grab yourself some some cool
gifts for the holidays get a game of
Thrones fidget spinner for someone you
love
um thanks Kendall Cup for sponsoring
this video you guys are fantastic people
over there anyway let's get on to what
cultures video here
[Music]
a great opening scene you can set the
tone for a movie going forward usually
or needs an idea of whether they're in
for a great time or whether they've just
wasted a tenner or so for it tickets and
nibbles sometimes a flick and have an
utter or slicing opening scene then send
everyone tumbling downhill from there
many films have done it Oh excellent
origin story it's not terrible from
start to finish we promise in the first
few minutes only for the remaining
hundred or so minutes to be garbage it's
downright unforgivable and these are ten
awesome opening scenes scenes with bond
infiltrating a base in North Korea and
raising hell the gunfights and numerous
explosion resulted and wonderfully
over-the-top hovercraft chase but see
tonight who's captured and tortured and
it grows a beard
everything goes past about tip from
there on in plastic surgery plot twists
invisible cars and increasingly
questionable CGI dine of the day's
become the bond that's trendy to hate
but it seems that most want to ignore
the fact that the opening was rather
enticing trailers the opening to Zack
Snyder's skimpy action fantasy thing is
an asylum after being blamed for her
sister's eventual death and a stepfather
bribes Poe Dameron to get a refreshed
track lobotomy
it establishes itself as a gritty and
emotional ROM the men track trash can
her dream sequences over-the-top action
set-pieces
skimpy outfits and bucket loads of false
eyelashes super punch is but a shell
cavern I'll be it with some pretty
brilliant visuals
service the first article superhero
super the first half is good hand cold
begins with Will Smith's character being
woken by a foul-mouthed kid who informs
it there's a high-speed pursuit underway
hungover and still drinking Hancock
hurtles through the sky and through
various signage to apprehend the
villains after saving brain Embry a PR
specialist he offers to improve his
public image there's the plot set
let's go downhill that's I think first
half eventually starting to take itself
too seriously yeah I've been doing some
take a back seat and we end up with just
another mediocre superhero film exact
number 7 jeepers creepers talk about a
movie that doesn't bore the audience
with foreplay Trisha Derry are driving
home from college for spring break when
a big rusty truck attempts to run them
off the road after they spotted shrub
dumping bodies into a chute by a church
the main antagonist the creeper chases
them once again this time successfully
running them off the road the audience
catch their breath and we continue from
there however an abundance of horror
cliches technique exciting opening and
the over explanation of the creepers
mythology pays two less plausible wash
over the whole ordeal the opening 13
minutes may be a wonderful way to kick
things off but after that point you're
gonna be the one wanted to be thrown
down that chute lemma 6 alien vs.
predator Requiem it may seem predatory
and ease of this film that didn't suck
AVP Requiem opens with a print alien
comprende lien but a tale very
productive from a predator predator ship
it quickly matures and all hell breaks
loose slaughtering everything it sees
and causing the Sun are hunting both are
apprehended by facehuggers but a late
distress and to me for some living
predator who sets off to earth to fight
the pradelio
alone I mean how cool does that sound
unfortunately the film doesn't deliver
on its boss open-air hair
to go to the titular characters battling
it out unfortunately
Requiem doesn't refine its footing after
that great introduction
number five desert sneaks up on you
the movie opens with the titular ship
with smooth music and happy dancing
passengers however an unidentified hand
pulls a lever which causes a huge role
of razor sharp wire to unspool and slice
across the dance floor
silence ensues as the guests look at
each other wow that's what happens in
that movie I haven't seen it quite Mitch
really irrelevant to this opening scene
being regarded as one of the most
inventive kill sequences of all of
horror the rest of the film lies in bits
first guests the generic Wow
predictability Markab scares even
critically ghost ships sunk number four
Ninja Assassin
I like Tokyo shooting wildly into the
dark attempting to defeat this unseen
ninja they're picked off one by one
similarly being sliced into one of the
gory bite-sized chunks as the legion
takes one final slice experiment is
revealed and you can choose even its
cause opening sequence and the Kari
doesn't bare-bones plot we universally
pound with no personality behind it even
gruesomely entertaining fight scenes
lose their novelty rather quickly number
three x-men origins Wolverine
most of you already know this one isn't
going to be great beginning in the mid
19th century x-men origins Wolverine
opens with Wolverine and Sabretooth
father being killed by an unknown
assailant who turns out to be war vomit
savers real father over with slick July
through the American Civil War both
world wars and the Vietnam War the pair
end up in front of a firing squad after
Sabretooth kills a fellow soldier shots
are fired boom title card despite great
performances from Jack Werner Schreiber
the film was a giant missed opportunity
the script was a total mess
butchering of Deadpool see your mouth
pinstripes and duel yes of course its
first eight minutes though we thought we
were in for a treat Super Troopers
to kick things off three stone college
students so up all of the drugs after
being questioned the cops drive off only
to loop around again repeating exactly
what they said before messing with the
three high gentlemen once a foul-mouthed
speeding motorist flies by the three
modes of bundled into the back of a
cruiser and a chase ensues when the
motorist is apprehended inside a bar
he's revealed to be a fellow cop playing
a prank on his buddies and famous with
the stoners even further by firing gun
shots away from there do you think
motorist killed these cops it precedes
to run outside and steal the cruiser
they're being held and terrifying them
in the process well except the windows
as much as this opening is entertaining
the remaining something only really
entertaining if you're about as jacked
up as those students however with a cult
following behind it a crowdfunded sequel
is actually on the way yep and number
one does way of the gun here's one
that's a great opening scene it
approaches them socks are clean in the
face and a huge fighting this is a great
opening oops arrived in the flight
players park of a long bow a left
bloodied and beaten there isn't really
much else to write home about
why dick dismissed it is a post
Tarantino no call failing to cover the
company a little bit the way of the gun
and even if the film isn't for everyone
the opening is one for the ages and
that's all this opening start for
everyone strong and fell apart as time
went on let me know in the comments
section below
head over to what culture dot-com for
more fun and frolic slike this and don't
forget to follow us on twitter i'm
thank you rich
I already subscribed buddy you're one of
the best channels out there man they
talked about some films on this list I
don't really care for Die Another days
opening scene actually I really hated
that movie I feel like as far as the
Bond movies go I'd be curious to see it
again in its entirety but that seemed
didn't really leave an impression on me
that's just bond opening yeah yeah it's
like yeah I'm used to this kind of thing
at the front of those it's not yeah it
wasn't like yeah this looks different or
enticing at all I guess that's why it's
number 10 on this list ah sucker puckers
punches of film though that it's pretty
awful film however TVs however like they
said here there's plenty to appreciate
in it as well
Sucker Punch is one of those movies that
I really wish worked somehow like I get
on paper what's cool about the concept
and like you see his world and for those
brief doses there I'm like oh yeah I get
why I thought this might be cool so I
could punch this a movie you can re-edit
to any song more do you want oh that's
gonna be able to make so many playlists
you can make so many different uses to
so many cool songs then take footage
from Sucker Punch you do almost every
Zack Snyder they take true that man he
should be making music videos that's
what he wants to make I don't agree
about a Hancock full-heartedly I was
talking about Hancock with someone the
other day I think the first half of
Hancock is pretty all right up until he
becomes a superhero then it gets all
crazy with like Oh Charlies there and
it's also a super thing man it gets all
caught up in gods and all these stuff
but I thought the first half of the
movie was all right well yeah I think
the first half of the movie is arguably
what works the best or maybe just
because it is the first half it's what
you get used to I don't hate the second
half of this movie I do except that it
doesn't work overall as a physics stuff
- seriously yeah it does but there's
stuff about why that happens in the
story that I do like I like the whole
thing about like we cannot be close to
each other otherwise we tear everything
around us apart that's every one of my
relation
ships I am toxic and codependent and
that's also it's also just you know you
can't call like the first 45 minutes of
something an opening scene AVP Requiem I
don't agree with that either I thought
the whole prayer to a lien pret Italian
thing was freakin stupid if that was
really stupid from the very beginning
not like it was cool that creature
deserves a movie that's good or
something just to see cuz I feel like
that's a cool thing to have seen but I
didn't feel cool while I was watching
that movie how I feel about the predator
lien is that if it had like a cheesy fun
kind of scary movie following it it
could have worked yeah but from the
beginning I thought it was stupid appr
didn't didn't get anything right for me
as I remember it and I don't know I have
a great likewise terrible it's horrible
yeah and then the open is another one of
those movies where the opening scene
also didn't leave an impression of me
again I'd like to rewatch it but I feel
like I was a little let down by the
ultimate like oh this is what we're
doing with the protis alien ok yeah
doesn't even do anything special what
name one unique thing the predator alien
can do I can't go ship I have not didn't
Sam Raimi produce this or his company I
think so thing that opening scene made
me go listening to everything he was
saying after that I was like that was a
crazy opening scene let's write go ship
they just promoted go ship that's what
movies get you mean if you bag on the
movie it's free promotion am i right am
i right for everybody don't watch EVP
Requiem I think Ninja Assassin is a very
misunderstood movie it's cheesy and
corny goofy and a silly violent romp
fest I loved it when I watched it I
thought it was so together right yes yes
we never saw theatrical but we saw the
test screening that was amazing III had
such a great bitching is the word to
describe it man hail a bitchin movie and
we were all watching and we've sort of
got that vibe like yeah this is kind of
cheesy and like the human drama element
so much fun yeah but it's cool and
badass and fun and again it's one of
those movies that delivers on what I
want
yeah you know then again we did see it
many many years ago and our perception
of film has changed changed over the
years so maybe when we go back watch now
as I was a brief boring a novel yeah but
I don't think I would feel that way I
just don't think I'd see it that way I
think I would still see what I saw at a
laundromat and he's gotten out like Jane
nice thing yeah that no boo yeah x-men
origins Wolverine I agree that the first
scene is cool you know Wolverine stabs
his dad yeah angry white boy they said
like it was good up and even through the
montage and them getting shot I did not
like that
I remember being hissed in the theaters
they montage over all this stuff I'm
like yeah I know you can't really
explore any of that but no scenes no
scenes in any of that not a single scene
a little boy you cover all history and
no scenes just a moxie
all they did was redo history and throw
Wolverine in there and that annoyed me
so much I started hating it from right
then in there what do you see the
trailer in your life it's gonna be many
periods how cool it's a montage that
sounds a trick you pulled on I see I
don't agree with that at all even the
montage accessible I think that in one
regard yes it is a very cool opening
montage thing I agree with you though
like in context of the rest of the movie
it makes the opening that much worse in
that it is just a couple images that are
and not much more than yeah yeah it
might be the trailer to the trailer made
this movie looks so good because the
trailer shows you that a lot of the
scenes to the montage so you think
you're gonna see explore that then you
realize oh they just filmed enough for
the trailer yeah yeah it's because of
that I'm like it's still technically and
like I think it's still a cool thing
what it means to what I expected and
what I got and all that stuff I know
that Super Troopers this is from
Canadian people okay
Canada's I don't know anyone who hates
this movie I haven't met a single person
who's like Super Trouper sucks I feel
like the only people who compelled to
talk about are the people who love it
well I feel like what culture are
British people yes would be British wit
and our really intelligent type of
comedy and then they say something like
Super Troopers
I think it's ridiculously stupid yeah
yeah so I feel very specific opinion
coming from the British people I have no
room to defend super troopers cuz I
myself have never seen it but when I see
clips of it I think it's pretty fun to
see them describing this silly even the
trailer for the second one at me Greg it
up every time I've seen a scene from
strippers it makes me live watch this
we'll have to watch him before the
sequel comes out so we really understand
all the references side jokes way of the
gun I'm so glad that they put this as
number one because it's not a huge film
you could have easily put x-men on here
or something or Super Troopers which is
more of a cult hit and then wave the gun
I don't know where the guns like cold
hit like they said I really enjoy the
hell out of this film cool I think there
are parts in the second half of act 2
and some of the beginning it back to
which are a little bit dull and I agree
that it does feel a little bit post
Tarantino knockoff a tad bit to me it
really does have this modern-day western
vibe and the characters are cool and
they have this really cool scene that
breaks into Act two so that's past the
opening scene and the finale is violent
and they're like shooting up a bunch of
old dudes Death Wish 3 to me it's a very
awesome film I think it's a really cool
film I love the tone and the problem
with the film is the opening scene is
cooler than a lot of the other the rest
of the movie that's an issue with the
thumb but it's not to say I don't enjoy
the rest of the movie cuz the rest of
the movie I think is really cool
this was my introduction to Benicio del
Toro and I think the only thing I've
seen a rhyme Felipe in the entire time
of the lines reduction Ryan Phillips
maybe my finale
I've never seen cool intentions or the
shooter show boy I wrap this up is there
any movies we could think of I'd have
like a great opening scene and a
terrible execution if there's one we
could think of
well there's one that comes to mind but
that doesn't quite fit the bill because
I I don't think the film itself is
agreeably terrible even though a lot of
people are not satisfied with it and
that would be watch men because Watchmen
everybody can agree that at least the
opening credits sequence with what is
that all along even the fight with yeah
and I've heard a lot of people who
dislike that movie even credit the
opening credits the opening credits and
the opening scene which is neat ooh yeah
yeah and I feel like I see people repost
the opening credits yeah a lot well guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
subscribe to what culture while you're
at it you can check us out on social
media we would really appreciate that
and please make sure to give some love
to today's video sponsor Kendall Capcom
enter our promo code rejects they got
they got a cool rep over yeah Black
Friday is coming up so you might want to
hop on that side do it